I served in the United States Marine Corps
for four and half years. I found Hillsdale
at the end of my last deployment, applied
and I came here basically three weeks later.
Hillsdale stood out from the other colleges
that I was looking at, in that it emphasized
teaching you how to learn, not what to think.
And, so I felt like I could take that and
kind of become a learner for the rest of my
life, rather than just learning for four years.
Once I decided to come to Hillsdale the big
flashing question was, what about financial
aid? I was just so impressed with how eager
they were to help me get here. Private donors
had stepped in and ended up providing basically
a full ride for me, a full four years here
at Hillsdale. And it's amazing to see that
because they understand how valuable this
is.
I think for most of the people coming from
the military, they already have this deep
sense of love and respect for our country.
But there's a lot of room for understand what
that country is. And, the things that really
established it and have preserved it. The
liberal arts and education here will not only
give you that but so much more. This foundation
not just for government and how we live in
society together, but in your own life an
understanding of what it means to be human.
And how to live the best life. You'll be able
to apply that and take that to whatever career
path, wherever it is go, whatever it is you
want to do, that's going to form every aspect
of your life.